[Musique]
voir des petits bonds ce nouveau report
bonsoir de qui nous sommes ravis de vous
rendre
ouvert aujourd'hui nous étions bien loin
nous adorons
joie de rentrée green white ra
avez-vous bien joué avez-vous bien
chanté avez-vous j'étais gentil et ça je
crois que quelques enfants ont été
depuis des méchants au bâton mais nous
étions en voyant
depuis ce cadeau entrons chez nous parle
non mon petit filet au petit garçon
jeux sont mais j'habite me petit je
relis toi nounours tu es trop gentil
essayons nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils aient eu une conduite
parfaite patron vous serez surpris
moi je vous le garantis alors nous nous
allons aussi à tue tête
bonsoir les enfants on est bien content
aujourd'hui pour bien longtemps
on va
dur tous les soirs
dire bonne nuit cher petit ami
bonne nuit surf et tysabri
et maintenant je descend vite retrouvé
mes petits amis pour le ch mais ne
traîne pas trop nounours un simple
aller-retour patron bonsoir maisons font
que voilà quand même vous en avez mis du
temps pour revenir par eddy dans trois
jours ma pauvre ce rhume il a la
majorité comme andy n'a pas justement il
n'est pas encore arrivé
ce petit ourson il n'est pas pressé le
copain de toi non plus j'ai beaucoup
pedebas soeur tout est prêt a three
cathédrale saint louis et des poneys et
des chevaux selle je suis mort de
fatigue ils feraient bien de se dépêcher
un pince à tour sans c'est pour ces
jours ci mais tu nous as apporté quelque
chose ça mais c'est gentil
tenez les enfants c'est ma soeur emilia
kivu les envois gers qu'elle tu redonnes
oui quel quart d'heure on aimerait bien
l'avoir muda serre si vous êtes bien
sage vous la verrez très bientôt je vous
le promets car moi
vous réserve une surprise
tu vas voir ce qu'on va être sage ya un
petit peu prône l on va se coucher
oui mon petit nicolas ma chère ce que je
suis un vieux mannesmann on est cochée
voilà renault
tu vois on a une à la lumière et on dort
presque on est sage sage les petits
oignons à demain
premiers chronos il faut être très sage
nicolas oui c'est bientôt noël
pimprenelle mais oui c'est bientôt noël
et tous les petits enfants du monde
entier se promettent d'être sage du
patron nous le gros on ferait bien de
troussage aussi on va essayer nounours
allons en route fidèle compagnon bonne
nuit des enfants faites de beaux rêves
beaudoin
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]